on poursuit également avec un autre lieu
historique qui s'anime avec le grand
spectacle pyrotechnique louis xiv le roi
de feu qui revient pour de nouvelles
dates en juillet ce soir vendredi 8
jeudi 14 et vendredi 15 pour l'occasion
le roi soleil lui-même et metteur en
scène du spectacle et nous transporte à
travers de multiples tableaux composés
de vidéos de feu et de lumière
véritable maître des artifices le groupe
f réinvente le faste des fêtes
extraordinaire des jardins du roi soleil
avec son grand spectacle pyrotechnique
louis xiv le roi de feu artificiers et
comédien les professionnels du groupe f
organise depuis 25 ans les plus grands
spectacles pyrotechniques à travers le
monde comme les feux du 14 juillet le
passage à l'an 2000 ou encore les coupes
du monde de football et de rugby au
groupe f on est tous artificiers avant
tout donc on arrive ya un feu a monté il
ya quelque chose derrière et un feu
d'artifice donc on y est tous très
souvent et n'ad'autre vraiment les
techniciens qu'ils sont sur une période
plus longue
mais les comédiens quand on arrive on y
participe un peu sur la fin
ensuite on montre nos montrent nos
propres structures ce qu'on joue ce
qu'on joue sur le plateau tout ce qu'on
porte sur le dos dans les mains
voilà sinon qu'ils me montrent ont
pendant une heure un enchaînement de
tableaux sur la thématique des planètes
orchestrée par le roi soleil lui même
pour illustrer son pouvoir suprême à
travers l'évocation du dieu mars et la
guerre le dieu apollon et sa beauté ou
encore jupiter souverain des dieux le
spectacle met les moyens croiser des
flammes des feux d'artifice de la vidéo
et des personnages lumineuse et porteur
de feu pour donner enfin du corps à ses
personnages on est rembourré et ça
permet aussi de porter nos batteries
toutes les antennes d'une met en
communication avec la régie et voilà
parce qu'en fait on est piloté par par
la région on peut s'allumer nous tous
seuls mais pendant le spectacle c'est
pas nous qui nous allumons le spectacle
se termine par un final somptueux
lorsque leroy finit par retrouver son
astre le soleil représentant sa
puissance sur tous et sa gloire
universelle